[Music]
what causes panic buying in the first
place i think we have to talk about what
panic buying is so i think quite often
right now especially in times like this
we see a bunch of empty shelves or when
covid first started oh my goodness
remember you and i did this episode with
tk coleman and we got really frustrated
there was a guy who was like stealing or
not stealing but like buying up all the
hand sanitizer paper towels like
reselling them at i don't know eighteen
hundred percent markup or something
absurd like yeah and making up the
number but yeah i think amazon got sued
over it actually for letting people do
that oh wow yeah and so
that's one type of panic buying but i
would like to extend panic buying i
think people panic by whenever there is
a sort of perceived loss
yeah whenever they feel as though
they might be missing out so it's fomo
the fear of missing out
and what do we do so anytime someone
creates a false shortage of something or
a real shortage
creates a faux urgency we see this you
and i used to be in the sales world and
quite often by our bosses and by the
corporation itself we were encouraged to
create a false sense of urgency to get
someone to act now to buy now and that's
a sort of low-grade panic buy i'll tell
you what if you go ahead and buy this
today i'll waive your activation fee
yeah if you go ahead and buy this today
i will waive the points on the loan or
whatever it might be it'll cost you 500
less if i can get you in this car
right now
and it creates
that sense of scarcity that oh no i'm
going to lose something if i don't act
now and so what does that do panicking
is never rational right no one panics
rationally right in fact
you can't panic rashly panic is always
an irrational response to some sort of
stimuli
in this case it's a shortage or a
perceived shortage yeah so we feel as
though oh no if i don't buy this now
then i may never have access to it when
i
need it yeah oh that's interesting man i
remember
uh the trader joe's near our place uh
when the pandemic happened yeah like the
shelves
just like
probably all the grocery stores across
the country were empty yes in fact i
remember a week later everything came
back in shelves were stocked trader
joe's had to put a
only two items uh only two of the same
item kind of restriction end to keep the
shelves from going bare again
which i don't understand like why all
stores just don't do that because
if you limit someone like hey we know
you want to buy everything but you're
going to be okay with just getting two
of this right and we'll have back in
stock next week right but if we panic
like that's when it starts to break down
but anyway
um i was talking to one of the cashiers
and they were saying that
they had um like the the best
week they've ever had by like 10 like it
was 10x
whatever they yeah whatever a normal
week was oh
because people were panicking yes and
that's my point is
corporations often
try to induce a low-grade panning now
they don't want to go over the top they
don't want you to truly panic and and
then you know you see the like the
doorbuster sales in our first film
minimalism
that is a type of of high-grade panic of
people actually trampling other human
beings literally the day after being
thankful for everything they have
and now it's the next day and now we're
going to trample other people because we
i think we just forgot about being
thankful now let's talk about the
essence of this where does it come from
it's about the fear of missing out well
oh yeah there's only one way to combat
the fear of missing out and that is to
understand what enough
truly is yeah now you and i ryan we have
this uh we call it the no junk rule
and it's in our minimalist rule book 16
rules for living with last you can
download it for free on our website it's
theminimalists.com
rulebook yeah it's also in our book yeah
those rules yeah we put all 16 of them
in love people use things and so but you
can download those for free and one of
those rules is the no junk rule and
basically everything you own can fit in
one of three piles it's either essential
it's non-essential or it's junk
now when you see those black friday
sales quite often we're trampling each
other for
junk yeah
at best we're trampling other people for
non-essentials things that might add
value to our lives but they aren't tr
truly essential and we can get by
without them right yeah now we panic
quite often because of what
we think that we don't have enough of
the essentials but that's because quite
often we're treating these
non-essentials or even these junk items
as though they are essential
and so we never stop to ask that
question what is enough how much is
enough food
what's going to happen if i run out of
paper towels what's going to happen if i
run out of pasta what's going to happen
if i run out of rice or i run out of
meat or whatever it is what is going to
happen in these scenarios am i going to
starve to death
if the answer that is yes then it's
probably an essential for you right
but if you run out of detergent one week
you're still going to be fine yeah and
and recognizing that you're going to be
fine
is the way to
deal with that fear that anxiety that
fear of missing out because realizing
like hey i'm probably not missing out at
all right but b even if i am missing out
i'm missing out
on non-essentials or maybe
i'm missing out on junk that i don't
need in the first place yeah
the the toilet paper shortage that that
really cracked me out man because
you literally have a bath
in the room
where your toilet is like toilet paper
don't get me wrong like i still view it
as an essential but there are very very
easy substitutes for that yes and the
fact that people were panic buying it
just kind of just kind of blew my mind
man and so i think panic buying is one
instance of
why some of these supply chain shortages
are there there are several other
reasons right now that we see these
empty shelves
and we're going to talk more about that
on the maximal episode this week but i
think part of it has to do with also the
the people who work at a lot of these
stores if a bunch of people get sick at
once
the coffee shop across the street i was
just talking to them about this there's
a blue bottle of coffee across the
street and i was there yesterday and i
was like hey thank you guys for being
here you know happy new year etc etc and
just grateful that that you're here and
they they said that they had to close 11
of their stores
because of
illness outbreaks whether it was covet
or something else so enough people were
sick they just could not staff the
stores well if you have the people who
stock the shelves or anywhere else in
the supply chain yeah the the truck
drivers the delivery people if it breaks
down anywhere in that sequence all the
way to the cashier or the person who's
bagging your groceries
if one or two of those links is missing
all of a sudden the whole supply chain
is interrupted yeah that's something i
really uh noticed during this pandemic
is how
easy easily the supply chain chain
breaks down and we take a lot of things
for granted even truck drivers like you
know i i think about being on the
highway and you know the truckers uh
they're always going slow in the slow
lane or like they're next to each other
like you know i i would find myself
getting irritated at truckers yes and
that has changed but that now i look at
them like oh like
yes i'll give you some of the road i'll
do whatever i can like without the truck
drivers we don't have the supply chain
yes you know you know where this panic
buying comes from too man the majority
of it what's that
the news um
because i can't tell you how many times
i've seen over the last two years the
news will say something like oh there's
going to be a gas shortage
and then all of a sudden there's a gas
shortage because people are buying it
because the news said there was going to
be a shortage
um same thing with like uh
it's self-fulfilling prophecy in a way
exactly yeah so yeah it's um
yeah it's it's kind of irritating but
like it's almost irresponsible of the
media
to cause this panic buying yeah it's
yeah self self-fulfilling prophecy so
um that's why i don't watch the news
anymore yeah well and i think you're
bringing up a great point in fact even
if there are supply chain issues and
there's panic buying without the media
panic
you're adding fuel to an existing fire
right and so there are actual supply
chain issues and when someone shows up
at the store i noticed this this past
last summer we were in tennessee
and there had been several supply chain
issues there you and i were down there
with dave ramsey and we we were doing
some stuff and i went to just a whole
foods to stock up on some food while i
was in town and i noticed entire aisles
where ryan they
they printed out
groceries and put it in the aisle to
make it look like there were groceries
there i felt like i was in some
communist country or something sounds
like north korea i've seen that in north
korea where they do that and so they
were doing this in nashville or franklin
tennessee right yeah and it freaked me
out but i also understood it looked
better than the sort of empty shelves
you wanted to be still aesthetically
pleasing but they just had some sort of
supply chain issue and and what that
causes and people see that they say uh
oh there's only uh seven rolls of toilet
paper left or seven i might as well just
go ahead and get all of them now because
this is all that's left yeah and so it
starts to panic buying which now there's
this small conflagration and the media
comes on and says oh my god hey everyone
don't panic but you should panic
don't panic but hey everyone else is
panicking yes
calm down while everyone else panics and
in fact that would be my message to
myself here is any time i see this panic
buying
i also feel that inclination maybe i
should also stock up yeah and so
i just step back for a moment and ask
myself
what do i need and what is enough
and if i can answer that with respect to
any individual item but then also answer
it more broadly do i actually have
enough and if the answer is no then what
do i need to get there usually to get to
enough we already have too much and it's
about subtraction
in these times where there are shortages
you may not have enough of something and
the question then is is there a
substitute or
can i go without for a period of time
yep yeah
so did you see anything during the
pandemic thus far
uh in a grocery store anywhere where you
were checking out and you saw like
someone panic buying a certain
certain something yes and it's
staggering yeah the things yeah so yeah
so what was it for you uh
well obviously we know about the paper
towels toilet paper all that stuff right
i saw someone with an entire cart full
of liquor
like a whole shopping cart
brimming i don't even know like it
seemed like it'd be so heavy i don't
even know how you would i can't believe
you could call me out like that on this
podcast
[Laughter]
guys i swear it was for my company right
oh man that reminds me of uh well yeah
it reminds me of a video of one of um
the the higher-ups like one of the
highest ups
in the jehovah's witness organization
he was filmed buying a grocery cart full
of like mcallen liquor anyway maybe
that's who i saw well it's funny because
i saw like i was just reading yeah maybe
i was reading on youtube some of the
comments under the video and like
jehovah's witnesses were like coming to
his defense like
oh well maybe it was for other people i
mean it was just it was just hilarious
man but but yeah liquor i saw wine i saw
cookies
i saw this guy with like panic buying
cookies panic buying cookies and i'm
just thinking to myself
man if you're stuck
and
the the only food you have are cookies
like you're you're okay with that
like
i don't know man i mean maybe for today
yeah right exactly yeah and so there are
certain things where it doesn't make any
sense to buy a lot of them period and it
almost never makes sense to panic by
anything yeah
because there are actual times to panic
if you are in a jungle with a lion
that's attacking you or you're walking
down the street and someone holds you up
at gunpoint
you're going to feel a panic response
naturally
the problem is we're now having that
same response to cookie shortages yeah
to alcohol shortages
and maybe we can just step step back for
a moment for a day for a week for a
month and say hey
can i do
without this
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel one hundred
percent advertisement free